One of the best things to do after removing a cancer is to or so what's the best thing to do after surgery really is the question if I have surgery and I have a cancer diagnosis, what should I do?
Well, I made a video. It's a blog post. It's on dealing with surgery. There's a new study that just came out that actually confirms something that I've said 100 times that we don't want to have elective surgeries.
If we could help it when we have a cancer diagnosis, that's why I've been told, I've told you guys multiple times that I'm not a big fan.
Okay, I had, but I had a bad stack to be because I had breast cancer, but now I'm going to have surgery to have breast implants and I understand I'm not a woman and I don't know what it's like to have to not have breasts and all the emotions that go along with that.
But when we perform a surgery of any kind, even to remove a cancer's tumor, the way your body has to heal itself is to up-regulate IGF-1.
Remember, IGF-1 is your growth hormone initiator.
So IGF-1 levels are how you heal.
So in order, if I even cut myself, how do I heal that cut? IGF-1 levels are up-regulated, being increased and that stimulates an increase in that m-tore pathway.
Remember, we've spoken about that at nausea.
So when we up-regulate the m-tore pathway, it increases my ability to heal by that wood is scarred over and I heal nicely and go, wow, look at I healed so well.
That's wonderful, but you did so by up-regulated m-tore and IGF-1 pathways.
When you up-regulate m-tore and IGF-1 pathways, with a cancer diagnosis, it is, I hate to say it, but it is like throwing gasoline out of fire.
So we want to do things to down-regulate the m-tore and IGF-1 after surgery.
The best way to down-regulate m-tore and IGF-1 is through fasting.
But I'll say it again, cancer patients cannot fast more than 24 hours at a time if we're talking about a true water fast.
That's why we talked about doing intermittent fasting or what's called time restricted eating.
So you actually are fasting every day, but it's only a fast of maybe 16 to 20 hours a day.
If your time restricted eating is limited to 4 to 8 hour window.
If you're eating within a 4 hour window, it should be a pretty tight time restricted eating window.
So that means you're fasting 20 hours a day, which would be a great thing for cancer because you'll have down-regulated an IGF-1 down-regulated m-tore down-regulated PDKs.
You could get the same benefit by using the fasting mimicky diet.
You go to the fasting mimicky diet five days a month and you stick to the diet that we put you on, you're going to have down-regulated IGF-1 down-regulated m-tore down-regulated PDK.
You do not want to go on a water fast for more than 24 hours if you have cancer because you'll have an up-regulate IGF-1.
The only exception to that is if you're doing chemo and you're going on a water fast day previous to the chemo and then the day of chemo.
It's a lot of information if you have questions, you can post another question on Facebook, rewind this video, and listen to that again.
The best way to heal from a surgery if you have cancer is to try to down-regulate.
Keep a head to a low IGF-1 in M-tore and you do that through the fasting mimicky diet.
That answers that, that will help.
So if you have more questions on that, feel free to call or to ask on Facebook.